we're now going to talk about a very
important operation
uh involving matrices and vectors it's
matrix vector multiplication
it's not something we've seen before but
where it's actually going to be used
basically throughout the entire
book and class from now on it's matrix
vector
multiplication so here's what it is
if i have an m by n matrix and n vector
so that means that the matrix here if i
write it out it's got
it's going to have m rows and
n columns then i can multiply it by
an n vector like that and
the way we denote matrix vector
multiplication is just
concatenation meaning you put the two
symbols next to each other so you just
say a
x um just like a lot of algebra
just put the two symbols next to each
other and it means the product in this
case it means
matrix vector product and so we'll call
if that's if it
if that's that what you get from the
matrix vector product
is an m vector and its i
entry is exactly this uh you go
across the eighth row of a
and you multiply those by all the
entries in x
um that's if you write you might
recognize that as an inner product and
you are right it is an inner product
right um so let's see how let's just do
a quick example now just to
make sure this makes sense um and it's
confusing at first with all the indices
flying around and you'll get used to it
and also right now you don't really you
haven't seen any applications of this so
it doesn't mean anything
so just consider this for the moment
kind of like the rules of chess
you don't ask why can you do that or why
can you not do that
it's just the rules for now okay let's
let's multiply let's do matrix vector
multiplication
here is a 2 by 3 matrix
and here's a 3 vector the first check is
when you multiply an m by n matrix by a
vector
x n that's the second dimension of the
matrix has to match
the vector dimension and that's true
here because this is 2 times three
and that's a three three by one if you
like or three vector
okay the result is going to be a two
vector so and sure enough it is now
let's see how to get it
well what you do is the first entry in y
which just happens to be three is you
take the first row of a
this is a this matrix here this is a and
this is
x and that is y we take we go across the
first row of x and we multiply by the
corresponding thing
or if you like you could say roughly we
take the inner product of the first row
of a
and x and that gives this and i mean we
can even check that it's zero
plus two and then plus one
the minus one times minus one and so we
get three okay and that's correct so
that's the idea that's matrix vector
multiplication
now we can interpret this tons of ways
right and
all of them we're going to use every
single one in this equal
and so the first is you can express this
as
simply if if you have the rows of a and
call them b1 transpose up to bm
transpose now b here are column vectors
right not row vectors but when you
transpose them they become row vectors
so b1 transpose is the first row of a
then you can write this y equals ax is
well it's b1 transpose x but which we
now know
is the inner product right so it's the
inner product of b
and x so you could think of matrix
vector multiplication as simply
it's like taking the inner product of
every row
of the matrix with the vector x let's
say
okay seeing them in a batch inner
product for example
and here's an example if i say what is a
ones
bold one is the vector with all entries
one
then that's a that gives you a vector
and it gives you the row sums
of a right so for example if i have a
matrix a
is you know 0 1 minus 1 2
then if i multiply that by 1 1
what i get is the first one is i get 1
here
and down here i get one right and
this is one is the sum of the first row
this one is the sum of the second row
right so
so when you see a1 you should be
thinking okay that's row sums
okay by the way these are these are kind
of important because you're going to
want to be
thinking about rows columns row sums
column sums all sorts
of stuff like that okay
column interpretation is also super
interesting and uses a concept we've
already seen
if i write y equals ax i can think of it
as y
is a linear combination of the columns
of a
so if a1 through a n are the columns of
a
then y is literally x1 a1 plus x2 a2
plus xn and so you can think of that you
can think of
vector matrix multiplication as super
compact notation
for forming linear combinations of the
columns of a
using the coefficients given by x okay
so here's a super important example it's
something you just absolutely need to
know
a times e j e j is the j th unit vector
is the jth column of a okay and so
it's kind of interesting right it so we
people you would say things like this
you would say that multiplying a matrix
by e j
picks out the jth column so let's just
check that just for fun
let's go to 0 minus 1
3 1 0
and let's multiply that by the second
unit vector
okay and what do we get well let's just
do matrix multiplication and i sort of
take the inner product of this with this
and i'll do it in my head
zero zero oh it's zero okay so i get
up here uh zero okay and now in my head
i'm going to take the inner product of
this with this
and i get 1. and sure enough
look what i just got i just got the
second column because this is
a times e2 equals
a2 okay so and we're going to use this
both ways if you multiply matrix by
a unit vector you're picking out a
column uh also sometimes
we will want to uh we'll do it we'll go
the other the interval should go the
other way
so okay um linear independence linear
independence
says that if a linear combination
of of a bunch of vectors is zero the
only way to do that is with
the coefficients being zero so now we
can write it in matrix spectrum notation
super compactly we would say the columns
of a are linearly independent
if ax equals 0 implies a equals 0.
and just to kind of put a seed in your
mind i'm going to say something more
about that
you could we can interpret it this way
if a and x
were numbers and i walked up to you and
i said hey ax is zero
product of two numbers is zero um
then what you know is one of those two
numbers is zero or another way to say it
is this
if i say that a x is zero and these
think of these as numbers now
zero and i tell you a is non-zero then
you could say well then x
has to be zero period okay um
or you could say things like i can
cancel a from
from this equation or something like
that okay now
that's what linear independence means
except it's for matrices and vectors it
says
it says that whenever if you have ax
equals zero we can conclude
x is zero right so roughly we can cancel
a or something from the equation
and so we can see there that linear
independence can be interpreted as sort
of like
of the columns can be can be sort of in
sort of interpreted
as a fancy matrix appropriate way of
saying a
is non-zero in the sense that it can be
cancelled so okay
that was all vague and weird but we'll
get to all those ideas later